Llevaba más de dos décadas en fuga
filtros Era uno de los cuatro prófugos
que aún se buscaban por su papel en el
genocidio de Ruanda el ex policía fue
detenido en Sudáfrica cerca de la ciudad
del Cabo se le acusa de orquestar la
matanza de más de 2000 hombres mujeres y
niños tutsis que se habían refugiado en
una iglesia católica del distrito de
kibumbú para los supervivientes del
genocidio la detención es un paso más
hacia la justicia
para los supervivientes del genocidio
que llevan años y años desesperados
porque se haga justicia
Así que es algo muy positivo
especialmente en este momento de
conmemoración
alrededor de 800.000 ruandeses en su
mayoría tutsis pero también utus
moderados fueron más sagrados durante
100 días a de extremistas utus en 1994
el tribunal de la ONU ha dirigido una
persecución internacional para localizar
a las figuras acusadas de instigar los
asesinatos masivos en los últimos años
se han logrado algunos éxitos como la
detención en Francia en 2020 de un
presunto financiador de los asesinatos
calle Chema vivía bajo un nombre falso
pero una investigación coordinada que
abarcó toda África llevó a la policía a
reducir la búsqueda a una granja de uvas
en la ciudad de Bart Mientras tanto la
ONU sigue buscando a los otros tres
prófugos restantes